at least eight people are dead and
others missing after heavy rain swamped
seoul's metropolitan region the rain
began on monday morning and had
intensified by evening in one part of
the city it was the most amount of
rainfall in 80 years the weather office
has predicted more rainfall in the
coming days
like fountains along the streets this
area of seoul filled up with water
turning roads into rivers
it even drowned the upscale district of
gangnam known for its designer outlets
and high-end cars
people thought they would be safe here
i couldn't believe that i was trapped in
a building with 40 other people in the
middle of gangnam district due to floods
it reminds me of the titanic i was so
scared my two little sons were waiting
at home so i wanted to go back home
which was only 10 minutes away but i
couldn't possibly move and that
situation was unbelievable today i
finally began to feel the impact of
climate change all these things are
caused by it
climate change is believed to be making
rains heavier and more erratic this was
south korea's worst rainfall in decades
the consequent flooding turned deadly
and brought buses and subways to a halt
roads and hundreds of buildings have
been damaged
i am shocked by the damage the same
thing happened around 11 years ago and
it is sad that the government has not
taken any measures
south korea's president had been
criticized for handling the disaster
remotely from home but early tuesday he
visited flood affected areas to see how
bad the situation is
the government should review the current
disaster management system from scratch
we need to account for these abnormal
weather conditions caused by climate
change
till that happens people are picking up
the pieces building things back up
but the rain hasn't stopped and is
expected to continue for days to come
let's get more of this story from frank
smith in cyril frank how bad is it and
is more to come
it's really bad 141 milliliters in one
hour that's an 80 year old record that
stood since 1940
now
tuesday morning this this morning people
were told to to go back to work it had
dried up
a little bit uh emergency crews were
repairing things pumping out some of the
water but then it started to rain again
at my location uh i was looking over a
sort of small stream that has a a
walkway of stones across it and i was
gonna go for a bike ride it was drying
up and then it started raining again the
stones across the street stream have
been submerged
and two meters above that the entire
walkways and bike paths on either side
of the stream are now submerged to the
tops of trees there is a bridge for
traffic going across this stream and
people are stopping now and looking at
the water just streaming
down what had been a stream which which
is now a river and you can see debris
and trees and tree stumps and and logs
also uh flowing down this river as this
unprecedented
you know uh
rainstorm has has struck the south
korean capital seoul and the corrupt
surrounding uh gyeonggi province here
barash
incredible stuff that you're saying uh
frank how are authorities responding
well they've been taking a lot of heat
emergency crews have been out there have
have been reports actually of of one
emergency crew member actually dying
being electrocuted uh while trying to to
to do some work but uh most of i think
the criticism is is political at least
some of it uh yoon sekul is is the
president he moved the presidential
office uh to a different location and
that new presidential office is being
remodeled and refurbished for him so
he's still living at home and community
he left for home last night on monday
night sort of when
this intense storm this monsoon uh
struck the the capitol region and he
didn't get back to his office in the
morning so he's under a lot of criticism
for working from home during this
critical period he did get out uh to one
of the locations that was seriously
effect affected by this flooding uh many
homes in in south korea are are
sometimes part way underground they're
semi basements and so you visited one of
those so to sort of try to reassure
people that government's doing the best
they can
bresch frank smith insole thanks so much
for bringing us that update
you